what is up everybody i am axel beats
here for anime uproar and today we're
going to be talking about one of the
most mysterious elements of the one
piece story the will of d is something
we've seen across 10 different
characters and with the end of the story
quickly approaching we're sure to see
the remaining members shake the world to
its very core before we get into it
though you know the drill if you're
enjoying the one piece content on this
channel remember to let us know by
leaving a like as well as a comment
saying who your favorite member of the
d-clan is
you can also subscribe to support the
channel as well it's a totally free way
to help us out and it makes a huge
difference for us with the youtube
algorithm finally this video will
contain manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned
alright so first off let's talk about
what the d-clan is and what implications
they have for the one-piece story way
back in the void century when the world
government set up their control the
d-clan were likely the people who stood
against them and while the ancient
kingdom remains to be a mystery they
passed down their beliefs and their
dreams through the will of d marked
through the middle d initial in the
clan's names at their core though those
who bear the initial d should be
considered the enemy of the world
government or as rosinante described it
they are the natural enemies of god
which in this case likely means the
celestial dragons but what does the d
stand for there are a couple theories
floating around but no conclusive answer
yet the most likely options are going to
be dreams a major theme throughout the
one piece story as a whole that stands
in the way of the world government's
iron grip destiny the thing that members
of the d-clan seem to be able to alter
and dawn the marking of something new
and the title given to the beginning of
the one-piece story through romance dawn
because one piece is a japanese story
it's pretty likely that the d will stand
for a simple english word as well as oda
specifically selected the letter d
rather than a japanese character and for
that english word to have an impact on
japanese audiences it needs to be
something that they'll all be able to
recognize which is why dawn is where i
cast my own vote here there are of
course other fan theories people think
things like dragon slayer danger
destruction dracula the guesses change
from time to time but most of these i'm
not a big fan of regardless of the
specific word though we know that every
character with the d initial seems to be
destined to shake the world and bring
about or cause a massive shift another
trait that i want to mention before
talking about the actual characters is
that those with the will of d seem to
smile both when faced with
life-threatening circumstances and as
they're actually passing away famously
we saw roger smiling at his own
execution luffy smiling as buggy was
about to behead him jaguar d saul
smiling when he was being frozen porcus
d rouge smiling when she named ace just
before dying ace smiled when he died law
smiling when dophie pointed a gun at his
heart etc etc etc it happens all the
time so at least to some degree there
does seem to be this idea that dying
happy is among the d-clan traits this
obviously creating ties to both odin who
died smiling with wano having big ties
to the void sentry and joy boy and of
course joy boy himself who has his
iconic smile and is a prominent player
through the void sentry while we don't
know if joyboy himself had a d in his
name it's at least implied that he's
very connected to the d clan just as it
is for wano as a whole an interesting
side note here is that the only member
of the d-clan who actually does fear his
own death and has been seen cowering in
moments of impending doom is marshall d
teach blackbeard finally the biggest
power that the d-clan has to offer is
their charisma and ability to draw in
and make friends wherever they go
something that mihawk even described as
the most dangerous power in the sea when
he sees it emerging in luffy but with
that said let's talk about the actual
d-clan members that we met in the
one-piece story as i mentioned earlier
we know of 10 so far monkey d luffy
monkey d dragon monkey d garp gold d
roger porcus d rouge port gusty ace
jaguar d saul trafalgar d water law
marshall d teach and rox d zevic and
what's interesting is that every one of
these characters with maybe the
exception of saul are mysteries within
the show and tend to have major points
of interest to fans or offer big twists
to their own personal story despite
meeting roger in the first panel of the
manga it was hundreds of chapters until
we really learned anything about him let
alone getting to see a flashback garp is
the hero of the marines but we didn't
learn why until just recently what's the
deal with teach dragon and zebic we
again know nothing about them almost to
this day despite them being huge players
in the story and even the characters we
are familiar with who we get to spend
time with are all mysteries in
themselves luffy's real devil fruit was
just announced after over a thousand
chapters with him ace's father was a
mystery until marine ford and law offers
the question of who he will use the
immortality operation on even in the
less interesting characters though like
saul you get this question of how the
d-clan reaches into other races sull was
a giant so where else could the d-clan
be found and while the term clan seems
to imply some kind of family how does it
seem to cross this racial line finally
rouge a character that we barely saw at
all has the question of how the hell she
survived that insane pregnancy all right
the last one's kind of a joke but all
the same these are all the characters
who are the most interesting in the show
and who make us ask the most questions
what we do know though is that each of
these characters has changed the world
and we're going to be starting with the
most recent addition to the d-clan that
we know of
rox d zebic zebik was the roger of
roger's day a man who wanted to be the
ruler of the seas and the captain of the
strongest crew in history but being
strong isn't enough to justify the d
initial we obviously don't know a ton
about zevik's life but we do know that
this man united edward newgate charlotte
linlin kaido and shiki which is insane
these are the strongest people that
ruled the next generation and even the
least impressive of them shiki has the
legacy of being one of roger's greatest
rivals
and being the first prisoner in impel
down the only way that rox's crew could
have been any crazier is if roger
himself had joined in and that all stems
down to rox himself it seems like
something about him being captain
allowed people to develop to their
potential and growing into pirates
capable of becoming legendary the
strongest man alive whitebeard big mom
the strongest creature in the world
kaido and the golden lion while they are
all goliaths in their own rights all of
their stories stem back to being on
rox's crew and in the abstract this also
meant that rocks enabled these people to
do everything that they would in the
future kaido's conquering of wano big
mom's control over totland and
everything in between beyond that for
rox to actually be defeated the world
government would have to join forces
with pirates and needed the help of
roger to take him down meaning this was
likely the starting point for the world
government understanding that they
weren't able to control things
independently anymore which would likely
be the seeds from which the warlord
system would grow and this warlord
program was inherently corrupt allowing
dangerous pirates to go without
supervision and would allow blackbeard
to cause the marine ford incident and
storm impel down without having any
trouble along the way it would allow
doffy to conquer dressrosa and crocodile
to take over alabasta inadvertently the
warlord system would also have some
benefit to luffy in several ways as well
though being something that connected
him to jinbe it allowed boa hancock to
go unchecked and for luffy to have a
place to train during the time skip it
had vivi crossing past with luffy as she
worked for crocodile
and put kuma in a place where he could
save the straw hats on sabaodi the
interesting thing here is that with the
d-clan it's very often that they act as
the first domino and you can trace their
impact to every other part of the story
if you want to hyper focus on one of
these warlord paths you could go
something like this rox inspired the
world government to work together with
pirates which leads to the warlord
system this warlord system picks up
jinbe who allows arlong to go free once
he becomes a warlord arlong then goes
out to kokoyashi village where he takes
things over holds nami prisoner and
offers her the ability to buy back
kokoyashi village for 100 million
berries and this leads her to stealing
from other pirates and finding luffy
along the way luffy then goes on to beat
arlong and earn his first bounty there
are so many tangential paths that stem
from every individual d-clan member and
it really is just a system of dominoes
hitting one after another the rox god
valley incident also earned monkey d
garp the title of hero of the marines
and proved roger to be the most capable
pirate on the ocean after all not only
did he defeat rox but he defeated all of
those future legends as well again we
don't know much more about rocks at this
point but i guarantee there is more to
his story likely involving blackbeard we
also don't specifically see his death so
we don't know if he was smiling but i
would be willing to bet that there is
more to his death as well moving on from
there let's go to roger roger would be
the first man to sail the seas and reach
laugh tale since devoid century like
rocks rogers crew also held people who
could change the world in their own
rights the future yonko shanks the
future warlord buggy d clown the
protectors of zou and red scabbards
inuwarashi and nekomamushi the
lighthouse keeper dr crocus the hero of
wano kozuki odin and his time traveling
wife toki and while not being official
members of his crew momonosuke and
hiyori would both be born on his ship as
well with hiori being instrumental in
taking down orochi and freeing her
people while momo would go on to support
luffy as he defeated kaido and as
chapter 1051 described he will be
someone who one day will be known far
and wide as one of wanos greatest
leaders not that roger himself was a
slouch competing with some of the
craziest pirates in history without
having a devil fruit of his own roger
was a good enough swordsman to overpower
odin with one swing and he had access to
all types of hockey we don't know any
unique or specific details about what
that meant for roger but we do know that
he could coat his sword ace with
armament and his conquerors was strong
enough to clash with whitebeards and
shake an entire island we however don't
really see him using observation though
it has been stated that he has it
finally roger has the ability to hear
the voice of all things something which
made him able to understand and even
write in the language of the poneglyphs
as well as hearing the voices of sea
kings
of course roger's greatest impact on the
world would be at his execution where he
inspired the great age of piracy by
telling the world about his hidden
treasure and the one piece and while in
most cases the will of d is more of a
spiritual or belief-based thing we do
see his will being directly passed on
through his straw hat which is now on
luffy's head of course roger would meet
porcus de rouge during his life and
naturally they did the old hanky-panky
both of them pretty hot here is where
rouge through pure force of will of d
held more than a double length pregnancy
to ensure that gold d ace could be born
safely ultimately resulting in her own
death from
you know giving birth to someone who is
effectively a one-year-old this action
though did allow ace to be born and
through that simple fact she did help in
shaping the future luckily monkey d garp
who was roger's rival in life was also
kind of a big softy roger had asked him
to take care of ace arguing that a
father's sin are no fault of the sun and
that garp's morals shouldn't allow him
to let an innocent child die so garp
brings ace to the dawn and again this
allows him to live and shape the future
going forward garf himself as i
mentioned was instrumental in defeating
rox and became the hero of the marine so
to say that he changed the world simply
through his actions with ace rocks roger
and rouge is easy enough to argue though
we can also add into garp's orbit kobe
taking him under his wing and developing
him into a hero on his own merit as well
and helping him turn into someone who
was strong enough to become an active
member of sword along drake and while we
don't see garp doing a ton of things in
the series we do know that he is crazy
strong he was roger's rival with roger
saying that they each almost killed each
other several times so it's fair to say
that garp was at least in the ballpark
of roger in his prime he was offered a
job as an admiral despite not having a
devil fruit and for contrast the other
admirals that we've seen have had things
like insane logias and the ability to
control gravity to the point where you
can call a meteor to the earth so i'd
say that's pretty high praise and in
some instances we see garp even going
above the other admirals as he was able
to swat away marco while he was using
his fruit despite akainu and kizuru seem
to struggle to do the same again no
devil fruit just being tremendously
strong we see him punching or throwing
insanely heavy objects like giant
cannonballs and chains with ease and he
even said himself that he crushed eight
mountains while training to fight shinjo
in terms of haki we know that garp has
armament and kobe was sent to see him as
a master for observation so it's implied
that he knows that as well and while we
don't see garp using conquerors i'd say
it's probably pretty possible for him to
have it but i wouldn't be shocked if he
didn't also just gonna throw in some
quick head cannon here but i personally
would like garp to eventually be the one
to kill akainu we see him needing to be
held back by sengoku when akinu was
going after ace and the day is quickly
coming where the fleet admiral and
luffy's paths will be crossing and
personally i don't think that garp is
going to watch a second grandson die but
that's just something that i would like
to see happen if he did defeat akainu in
this way it would definitely be
something that shook up the world in a
more canonical sense though garp is in a
pretty unique position of being the vice
admiral working for celestial dragons
that he hates so much so that he even
refused to become an admiral because it
would give them greater control over him
which also raises an interesting
question there are only ever three
admirals at the start of the story those
were akainu aokiji and kizuru if garp
had accepted the station of admiral one
of those would never have been promoted
and as each of them offers their own
distinct sense of justice it would
drastically change the balance of power
within the marines themselves we've seen
how akainu functions for example he is
quite literally a kill first and asked
questions later kind of person when it
comes to what he believes to be just
taking away his power would surely
change how things played out in
countless incidents it would also have
meant that aokiji never would have had
to fight him for the position of fleet
admiral
and he would have never lost or left the
marines as a result similar arguments
could have been made for if aokiji or
kizuru didn't make it into becoming
admirals but the point still stands garp
making the choice to not be an admiral
shaped the marines as we know it today
now we have been circling a character
for a little bit now so let's finally
talk about ace the child born in secret
the heir to roger's bloodline the second
division commander of the whitebeard
pirates the adopted grandson of monkey d
garp and the final surviving big brother
that luffy has and oh did that last one
not quite age well the point is ace was
a super important character that's tied
to some of the most influential people
in the story and that doesn't even bring
in his ties to wano or yamato not to
mention ace had the mera mera nomi the
logia fruit which allowed him to turn
into create and manipulate fire ace
doesn't have a ton of fights in the
series but we do see him doing some
phenomenal stuff in the little that we
do for example in his first showing off
of his fruit we see him destroying a
line of ships with a single fiery fist
it's not just his fruit though ace also
has conquerors which he awakened as a
child but as far as armament and
observation we still just don't know
much in one piece novel a we see him
using armament to fight vice admiral
draw and observation is kind of in the
same boat ace trains with thatch to
learn it but we don't really ever see it
being used which is why when blackbeard
defeats him and brings him to impel down
the world begins to change
ace was slated for execution and as a
result all of the world's powers saved
for big mom and some of the supernovas
converge on a single point of marineford
the world government brings an army
along with all three admirals all of
their vice admirals mihawk doflamingo
gekkomoria a small division of
pacifistas and boa hancock is sort of on
their side sometimes depending on who's
in her way and all of these phenomenally
powerful people
waged war against every division of the
whitebeard pirates luffy and the escaped
prisoners of impel down including
crocodile
jinbe ivankov and buggy not just those
two groups though blackbeard's crew
along with his newly acquired prisoner
crewmates like shiryu avalo pizarro
katarina devon and san juan wolf all
arrive to capitalize on the war as well
ultimately killing whitebeard and
stealing his devil fruit trafalgar law
shows up then shanks and the red-haired
pirates who had arrived after stopping
kaido who was also on the way to show up
and luckily shanks does manage to both
stop kaido and end the war as a whole
genuinely unless the big mom pirates
arrived with the other supernovas and
the remaining straw hats
every relevant character in the story
was there this is the super smash bros
ultimate of pirate wars and it all
started with ace being captured and put
up for execution ace's death though did
two specific things as well firstly it
broke luffy leading to a scene where
jinbe would need to get him back on his
feet in amazon lily and where luffy
would go on to make the decision to
spend two years on ruskina with relay
training the other point being that
whitebeard would go on to sacrifice
himself so all of the rest of his men
could get away and declaring that the
one piece was real
reigniting the great pirate era i
mentioned blackbeard a bunch there as
well and he has
a huge impact on the story blackbeard is
a schemer with the original plan being
to join the whitebeard pirates and bide
his time until they came across the
devil fruit that he was looking for the
yomi yomi nomi this fruit would
eventually be discovered by thatch and
blackbeard would kill him to steal the
fruit for himself before defecting from
the crew this inspires ace to chase him
down which blackbeard uses as an
opportunity to capture ace allowing
blackbeard himself to become a warlord
and act freely all while triggering the
marine fort war and giving himself
access to impel down there he would
steal all the new criminals for his crew
and now a stronger force than ever he
could enter the war and steal
whitebeard's devil fruit allowing him to
become a yonko a position that gives him
so much power that he can do really
anything he wants until he's ready to
head to laughtale or topple the world
government and become ruler of the seas
just as zebic wanted to be in the past
speaking of we don't know what their
connection is between blackbeard and
zevik we know it will be fleshed out and
i'm sure it will add a lot more to
blackbeard's story as of right now
blackbeard is easily one of the biggest
threats in the story the darkness fruit
allows blackbeard to swallow up the
world around him into black holes but it
also allows him to turn off other
people's devil fruit when he touches
them as we saw with ace
it's unclear if the darkness fruit is
also a catalyst for blackbeard being
able to steal devil fruits but that
could definitely be why he wanted this
fruit specifically of course that is
just a theory regardless of the real
method of devil fruit theft he's also
accrued a crew full of stolen abilities
as a result and finally blackbeard also
has the guragura nomi a fruit which is
said to be able to destroy the entire
world by creating shockwaves that would
cause it to quake and split apart
interestingly blackbeard has not been
shown or stated to have conquerors
hockey yet though i'd imagine that he
does we know that he does have
observation hockey specifically as he
uses it to gauge luffy's growth and we
know that armament hockey is also
something he has as we learned from the
fever cards and while not being part of
his arsenal directly i do want to talk
about teach's body we know that teach
has a very strange body this is
something that gets brought up quite a
bit throughout the series but this
causes things like him not needing to
sleep furthermore when leaving jaya
luffy and zoro refer to blackbeard as
not a he but a they a group of people
and this might tie into why he's able to
have multiple devil fruits despite no
one else being able to do so there are
several theories around all of this be
it that blackbeard is actually three
people or three personalities yadda
yadda but whatever it is this weird body
allows him to have multiple devil fruits
and when you combine that with his
ability to strategize it makes him a
very deadly force
next up we have luffy's father and garp
son monkey the dragon again this is a
character that despite being a fan
favorite we know nothing about like
we've seen this dude maybe a dozen times
in the entire series if we're lucky and
maybe total he's better than enough
pages to fill up one chapter and all we
really know about him is that he's the
leader of the revolutionaries and who
he's related to and that's kind of it
even so though the fact that he runs the
revolutionary army and is the most
wanted man in the world speaks volumes
whitebeard was the strongest person in
the world big mom runs an empire kaido
is the strongest creature and blackbeard
has two devil fruits as a result of
making a fool of the world government
but none of these characters are the
most wanted instead dragon is dragon
represents something to the world
government that they fear
more than all of the yonko and more than
being made into fools and that's because
dragon is the human embodiment of the
will of d
he is an agent specifically working to
change the world and bring about a new
age a new dawn if you will so while we
don't know anything really specifically
about what he's done or what he will do
it's very easy to understand what he is
and why he's considered to be dangerous
and that doesn't even bring into account
his abilities we can assume that he does
have armament hockey as he managed to
grab smoker back in log town and like
luffy it's probably safe to say that he
does at least have observation though
conquerors is probably on the table as
well the big thing with dragon is his
storms we don't know if it's a devil
fruit or not but we have seen it several
times where a green storm will arrive
just before dragon does and there seems
to be some kind of control to it as a
lightning bolt specifically saves luffy
just before he's executed like i said
it's unconfirmed but if dragon does have
a devil fruit that controls the wind or
controls storms that's pretty huge for a
pirate-based story
our next d is jaguar d saul a former
marine vice admiral who allowed nico
olivia to escape the marines clutches
and who saved nico robin from the
assault on ohara by saul making active
choices to abandon his posts for what he
believed to be right he allowed robin to
eventually cross paths with crocodile
and then luffy and as we know robin is
the last person on the planet who can
read ponoglyphs she is one of the most
important characters in the world she's
the key to finding laughter and learning
the truth about the void sentry and as
such saul opens the door to allowing the
truth to be revealed and likely to the
ultimate downfall of the world
government second to last we have
trafalgar law the character who sets in
motion the plan to take down the yonko
kaido something which in itself will
impact not only the country of wano but
also the entire world law also made a
name for himself during the rocky port
incident the same one that made kobe
into a hero and not to mention law also
was a warlord that leveraged that
position to put him in a place where he
could start his takedown of doflamingo
however while all of these things are
tremendous i don't think any of them are
going to be the reason that law changes
the world instead i think that's going
to come down to his devil fruit law has
the ape ape nomi the devil fruit which
allows him to freely manipulate the
people and objects around him and while
that is super powerful on its own the
devil fruit actually earned the title of
the ultimate devil fruit for a different
reason at the expense of law's life he
can perform something called the
immortality operation granting someone
else eternal youth and this is something
that could have insane ramifications
especially if it ends up in the wrong
hands and it's something that would
never be introduced if it wasn't going
to play a role in the story at some
point as such i think that the method or
choice on who law chooses to perform
this surgery on will be the reason that
he changes the world conversely we could
look at someone like imusama who seems
like they already are immortal possibly
so maybe that had been performed on them
by a previous ape ape user on top of
that we have blackbeard who knows how to
steal devil fruits and could easily
force feed the apiape to one of his own
henchmen and then force them to
sacrifice their own lives to give him
immortality the ways in which this fruit
could shift the balance of power in the
world forever are countless and it's
obvious that it will eventually play a
massive role in how this story reached
its conclusion and finally we have
monkey d luffy the protagonist of the
series the inheritor of roger's will the
descendant of the hero of the marines
and the world's most wanted man brother
to portuguese the ace the user of the
mythical nika fruit the return of joy
boy and someone who has challenged and
changed the fate of those around him
throughout his entire journey luffy has
done so many phenomenal things in the
series but the greatest strength he has
is that he can manipulate those around
him he draws them into becoming his
allies makes them believe that their
impossible dreams could be a reality or
tear down the nightmares that they are
living through and we see this as early
as shellstown when he meets kobe turning
him from a scared and wimpy brat into
someone who was willing to stand up for
their dream and make the first step
towards attaining it we see this with
every one of his crewmates reinforcing
zoro's belief in becoming the world's
greatest swordsman this to the point
where zorro even humbles himself into
eventually asking mihawk to train him we
see luffy helping sanji realize that
he'll never reach the all blue if he's
stuck in the bharatiya luffy frees
kokoyashi village from the tyrant arlong
he does the same thing in drum kingdom
with waffle alabaster with crocodile and
skypia with eneroo and so many other
places be they kings warlords or gods
luffy will stand with those around him
to battle tyranny create freedom and
turn dreams into a reality luffy's fruit
the mythical mika allows him to have a
rubbery body that resists electricity
and is able to move and bend in any way
he sees fit he is limited only by his
imagination at first this is all very
simple stuff but of course we do see his
imagination being turned more and more
into reality as he includes things like
gear second third fourth and finally
fifth like roger luffy also has access
to all forms of haki we've never seen
him coat a weapon with armament but he
can cover his body to the point where
he's nearly invulnerable in tank man he
can use ryuo he has observation which
allows him to see slightly into the
future and his conquerors is strong
enough at this point where he can
enforce his attacks with it like he did
against kaido unlike other characters i
can't go arc by arc and tell you how
luffy has changed the world because he
does it in small ways so often that i'd
be here forever but all of those ripples
add up and he makes them in every
kingdom that he crosses and the waves
that he creates spread to impact people
and places worldwide he is the savior of
the downtrodden and the oppressed and
it's what makes him the perfect
inheritor for the nika devil fruit and
for the title of joy boy the nika fruit
has the power to turn imagination and
personal spirit into reality and that is
the will of d made into a tangible force
standing up for those under tyranny
making dreams come true the sun god nika
represented a change for all of those
that he liberated they wouldn't be
slaves anymore and they could start new
chapters of their own lives fittingly
the sun god would bring about a new dawn
for all of those who crossed paths with
him
and that is what the will of d is all
about
and
then there's blackbeard and zebic which
seem to actively go against all of that
which at first does seem like a
contradiction however that's kind of an
integral theme of one piece as a whole
there's a balance to everything the
marines are painted as this evil group
but then you have people like garp
aokiji kobe smoker saul and so many
others who prove that there are good
people there too pirates are supposed to
be bloodthirsty greedy monsters but then
you have the straw hats and shanks and
law and how many other good pirates from
along the way who just want to be free
and follow their dreams no group is a
monolith and this is a story of
individuals so just as most of the d go
against the world nobles as a result of
following their dreams not all dreams
are positive and blackbeard wanting to
throw the world into chaos does
technically get rid of the world
government it just doesn't bring things
to a better place but that's gonna wrap
things up for this look at the users of
the will of d
and how they affect the world
this has been a really interesting topic
for me since beginning one piece so i
really hope that you guys enjoyed as
much as i did of course if you did
remember to leave a like and comment
down below and maybe even consider
subscribing for more great one-piece
content in the future
you can also follow anime uproar at
anime uproar on twitter and instagram or
you can check out my own channel called
axle beats but with all of that being
said thank you so much for watching and
until next time remember to stay
excellent